hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about essential fatty acids okay
essential meaning must be consumed from
the diet your body doesn't make it
there's basically two different types
you got omega-3 and omega-6 okay and you
should have a 1 to 1 ratio
the names are very similar but they're
little confusing this one is called
alpha leno
lenok this is linoleic okay very similar
but different I recommend not
necessarily worrying about getting your
ratios you should have a 1:1 ratio
because it would be almost impossible to
figure out from your foods to balance
this and balance that I would just
consume some of these foods flaxseed
chia seed hemp seed and walnuts ok that
will give you a nice balance of these
fatty acids now of course some of these
fatty acids are also in the vegetable
oils and vegetables themselves I don't
recommend the oils that some of these
are in like a soy or corn oil but if
you're eating a healthy diet you should
get the right ratios but the point is
this if you're deficient in this
specific value acid it'll stunt your
growth a little bit it'll also you'll
feel weaker you won't have the stamina
your vision can go bad learning
difficulties so how important is this to
give to a child mood changes and omega 6
fatty acids has a function of
transferring oxygen to the lungs so it
exchanges it helps that oxygen exchange
it's like an oxygen magnet it pulls you
agent in and it allows it to go into the
blood the hemoglobin and also directly
to the cells so we really need this
fatty acid membrane in our cells to
allow the oxygen to transport through it
but essential fatty acids really make up
the structure of your cell membranes and
also a lot of the structures inside the
cell they're called organelles a little
machinery that run the cell now if
you're deficient in in this fatty acid
you have a lot of skin issues zima hair
loss dehydration slow healing sterility
in a male body miscarriage and female
arthritis heart problems it also will
help you recover so let's say for
example you do this intense workout and
you're soaring of this lactic acid
buildup boom take some flaxseed oil or
some chia seed oil and you will recover
faster why because the oxygen carrying
capacity and also it gets rid of lactic
acid it's an anti-inflammatory too now
together essential fatty acids looking
at the whole thing there's some
classical symptoms one is dry flaky
peeling cracking skin okay you probably
know people like that and you see them
and I usually see like older men with
these kind of crusty skin you see in
their ears that's that they need this
right here bumps in the back of the arms
right through in here that's omega
that's fatty acid deficiencies so go
ahead and apply this if you have these
symptoms start consuming some of these
foods right here and put your comments
below thanks for watching
first up please and yeah you'll get
future updates that's right updates I
knew there was a word how about I'm not
sure just press it press the subscribe
button and I will keep you updated on
the future event